what is a left hand in general doing in
the European Parliament and ghazals
aubert director-general if the EU
military staff came to discuss to use
military capabilities was the Security
and Defense Committee since 2007 deu has
had Prince national battle groups made
up thousand five hundred men but these
battalions have never been used in the
military situation so what is their
purpose they are training framing and
well we have a big discussion on this in
Sweden why do we have them I would like
to see the battle groups with
possibilities to act this battle groups
have been used to train local troops in
conflict zones and to assist in
disarmament as was the case Molly
recently some Emmy peas would like take
things further the situation requires
the you to be equipped for all kinds of
situations for all kind of possibilities
including military one the use of
military forces is dependent on
political will a majority of MEP is
expressed a willingness to devote more
money to the military budget that covers
these battle groups the next step is to
vote in the plenary session in May
you